okay a little bit more on this claudian
gay story because you know as always um
as they say you know it's not the crime
it's the coverup and so uh it's it's the
attempt by the
media to cover for claudi and gay uh
that becomes the story in and of itself
I mean they could have just
said after she was exposed as a play the
first time that a plagiarism exam
because really it should be a oneandone
with plagiarism when you're an academic
and you're the president of what
supposed to be one of the most
prestigious schools in the world should
be like one example of plagiarism and
you're done and so the media the left
all the they could have just said after
the first example oh okay well turns out
she's a plagiarist we condemn that uh
she should be fired and then and then
you move on and then if you're on the
left yeah you try to go find some other
quote unquote diverse person who's not a
plagiarist and then and they could have
just done that um and it and then the
whole thing
wouldn't be nearly as embarrassing for
them but you've got all these media
Outlets who have decided to just
continue to continually step on the
rake um in an effort to uh to defend
Claudine gay you know and so you end up
with men it's like it's like the of
course the infamous moment from CNN
where they describe the BLM riots is
fiery but mostly peaceful and so there
have been many little fiery but mostly
peaceful moment Ms from the media about
this
story and this is and we went over a few
of them in the opening
monologue uh this is maybe the worst
one uh and and it only it just you start
reading it and it gets worse and worse
and worse so we'll walk through this but
here's the AP headline about this all
this headline is Harvard president's
resignation highlights new conservative
weapon against colleges plagiarism
let's just stop there for a second just
like pretend you didn't know anything
about any of this okay you didn't know
anything about the Claud and gay
story and you saw that and you also
didn't know anything about a the ap's
political leanings so you've really been
just living in a cave somewhere and you
read that
headline how would you even interpret
that I mean you would it certainly
sounds like conservatives are using are
plagiarizing themselves
okay so conservatives are somehow using
are committing
plagiarism in some sort of effort to
attack
universities like plagiarism is our
weapon that we are using so it makes it
sound like we are the
plagiarists but no in fact the weapon is
the plagiarism that these that the
University president herself
committed so our weapon is pointing it
out it's noticing
so really what the headline should say
is Harvard's president's resignation
highlights new conservative weapon
against
colleges noticing
plagiarism that's our weapon is that
we've noticed it and as we've learned
and when it comes to plagiarism and we
comes to so many other things that uh
the cardinal sin that you can commit as
a conservative is to notice things
you're not supposed to notice really
anything until they give us permission
they'll give us they certain things were
allowed to
notice um but only very specific
things so let's just read a little bit
of this
article American higher education has
long viewed plagiarism as among the most
serious of offenses accusations of
plagiarism have ruined the careers of
academics and undergraduates alike the
latest Target is Harvard president
Claudine gay who resigned Tuesday
reviews by Harvard found multiple
shortcomings in Gay's academic citations
including several instances of D
duplicative language while the
university uh concluded the errors were
not considered intentional or
Reckless oh they're they're just
duplicative it's not plagiarism you see
this language is not it's not
plagiarizing something else it's just
duplicating
it without
attribution
um while the university concluded the
errors were not considered intentional
Reckless and didn't rise to misconduct
the allegations continued with new ones
as recently as
Monday many came not from her academic
peers but her political foes led by
conservatives who sought to oust gay and
put her career under intense scrutiny in
hopes of finding a fatal flaw her
detractors charge that gay got the top
job in large part because she's a black
woman which of course is exactly why she
got the job and also
remember that's actually of course
everything I'm I'm reading now is all
nonsense obviously and this is not how
it actually worked it it it didn't work
like she got the job and then
conservatives said oh we're really we're
really mad that they gave that they have
this diversity higher and so we're going
to find a way we're going to go looking
for something you know we're going to go
looking for
ammunition if that is what happened it
would still be
fine like it doesn't actually matter
what the motives are of the people who
find the plagiarism what matters is the
plagiarism um but that's actually that's
not easy in what happened as we went
over in the opening
monologue this stuff was known before
she was even
hired and there were some conservatives
who were trying to help Harvard out by
saying hey she's a bad choice don't hire
her you're going to embarrass
yourselves and they chose to do it
anyway AP continues in Gay's case many
academics were troubled with how the
plagiarism came to light as part of a
coordinated campaign to discredit Gay
and force her from off office in part
because of her involvement in efforts
for racial Justice on campus her
resignation came after calls for aler
from prominent conservatives including
representative at Le stepanick uh and
Harvard alumna Harvard alumna and Bill
Amman a billionaire hedge fund manager
who donated Millions to
Harvard and then they just so they just
in at the top of the article they
indicated that this wasn't actually uh
plagiarism and then a little bit later a
few paragraphs down paragraphs down they
say what's really troubling is how the
plagiarism came to light so it is
plagiarism then but the plagiarism isn't
troubling it's how it came to light
that's troubling well as we head towards
a presidential election in November
there's one thing you can be sure of
2024 will be a tumultuous year how will
your hard-earned savings Faire will you
already see the impacts of inflation at
the pump in the grocery store the dollar
continues to lose buying power faster
than wages can increase how are you
protecting your savings consider
diversifying with gold from Birch gold
group for decades gold has been the
choice of investors and central banks to
hedge against inflation if you have an
IRA or 401K from a previous employer
that's just Gathering dust call Birch
gold and they will help you convert it
into an IRA in Gold you won't pay a
penny out of pocket they'll simply
convert the 401K into physical gold
which unlike digital currency can't be
tampered with just text Walsh to 9898 98
and Birch gold will send you a free info
kit on gold with an A+ rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
satisfied customers and the exclusive
gold company of the daily wire for the
past seven years you can trust Birch
gold to text Walsh 298 9898 to claim
your free info kit that's Walsh 298
9898 and secure your savings now so you
notice that they aren't really disputing
the plagiarism
charge uh what they're saying is yeah
she's a plagiarist but you only care
about that because she's
black they you know they're what they're
doing they're basically treat to use a
football analogy because I try to fit
them in wherever I can uh they're
basically treating plagiarism like it's
holding in football and you know fans if
you're a fan of a of a team anytime the
ref calls holding you're going to
complain about it and and you're going
to say when it comes to holding you're
kind of right that well you could call
holding on every Play Everybody holds so
it's it always it's it always feels a
little bit arbitrary when they call it
because you can all you could call you
could look for holding and charge
everybody on the defense with holding
everybody on the offense withholding um
and that's kind of what they're doing
with plagiarism sudden what was once
considered the greatest sin for an
academic has become something that
according to the media on the left it's
like everyone does it so we should just
let it
slide I mean yeah if you're if you go
looking for
plagiarism with a with a an ivy league
university president of course you're
GNA find
it um and I I've seen this from the left
too they say oh well you know if you're
going to hit claudi and gay for this
well then you should scrutinize every
college professor and every president to
see if they plagiarize
too and I guess we're supposed to object
to
that but instead we say yeah absolutely
sounds good but like yeah let's do it
let's look at all these
people I mean if claudian Gay's
plagiarism is actually as routine as
they make it
sound then by all means
let's let's fire all the other
university presidents
too including the white
ones that definitely in fact I'd be in
favor of this just to show you how much
I believe in Racial equality I say maybe
we should just fire all of the
University presidents automatically in
one Fell Swoop and then look for the
plagiarism
afterwards so when it comes to I'm all
for a shoot first ask questions later
kind of approach when it comes to this
whatever results in in more University
presidents and University administrators
unemployed I'm in favor
of but if you don't like that approach
then I guess we're left with only firing
them after the plagiarism has been
proven and with gay it has been
proven literally 50
times I mean this whole thing is just
the left claims that they aren't
lowering standards in the name of
diversity right they say that uh we can
prioritize diversity and inclusion but
not lower standards they claim and we
already know that's a lie because
obviously if you are hiring somebody
based on anything other than
Merit you are lowering
standards but here we have the most
dramatic and glaring evidence yet that
the standards are being lowered I mean
they have lowered the standards so much
they have obliterated the standards to
such an
extent that they are now excusing
plagiarism by University
presidents they will now accept
plagiarism in the name of diversity you
you you honestly cannot lower the
standards more than that and I realize
in saying that I might eat my words
because they're going to look for a way
to do it every time you think the bar
can't get lower I mean they dig a hole
and lower it even more but
uh when you consider the job it's like
plagiarism is the worst thing you can
do it's like U I don't know
hiring a chef for a five-star
restaurant who who serves microwaved
chicken nuggets it's just you you can't
lower the bar any any lower given the
job I mean there are worst things there
are worse things a person can do in life
than plagiar
eyes but but
um when it comes to a university
president and that job specifically it
it's it's as bad as it gets but I
haven't even mentioned the best part of
this AP article and before we move on I
have to mention it so let read this
paragraph to
you Chris Christopher rufo a
conservative activist who helped
orchestrate the effort guke celebrated
her departure as a win in his campaign
against Elite institutions of higher
education on X formerly Twitter he wrote
scalp as if gay was a trophy of
violence invoking a gruesome practice
taken up by white colonists who sought
to eradicate Native
Americans and actually this so here so
that's the end of the
sentence uh he he said scalped which
evokes scalping which was done by white
colonists against Native
Americans and now
anyone with even a rudimentary knowledge
of the history of of the new world uh of
this part of world you you know that
scalping yeah now it is true that white
colonists in some cases did take up the
practice of scalping but guess where
they learned it
from okay in some cases the white
colonists would yeah they would collect
scalps because they saw the Indians
doing it and I guess few of the white
colonists said looks like a good idea we
should try that which certainly is not
something that can be
justified but no this this is actually a
Native American practice and there's
evidence of scalping that goes back
hundreds of years before any white man
uh set foot on these
Shores
so the AP they went apparently and I'm
I'm trying to sort through this but
because there are two different vers
versions of this
article and so it appears that at some
point over the last few hours they went
back and they changed they edited this
sentence so that now it says in scalping
invoking a gruesome practice taken up by
white colonists who sought to eradicate
Native Americans and also used by some
tribes against their
enemies they went back and changed that
they yeah
okay because they were hoping that
nobody would notice that they could just
throw that in and then a bunch of people
noticed it and said that's insane and so
now they went back and yeah okay a few
Native Americans did it
too and by a few we mean like every
Native American tribe did
this um they
just they cannot stop embarrassing
themselves it's amazing if You' like to
see what else I have to say you can
access my full show by going to
dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there goded